where do you struggle most with writing
screenplays interestingly enough it's
just writing I think I've been writing
for so long that I'm at the point now
where I wish there was some really good
software where I could just talk and it
would just write it in script format for
me you know the physical act of getting
it out of your head I think is the
hardest part now because it's usually
most most creatives especially a few
storytellers there's never a time when
you don't have stories just constantly
coming into your head like ideas and you
know and even if you flush out the idea
fully when it's just a physical act of
typing you know I think that's the thing
when I was really young it was fun
you know just young and you just type in
and everything's great and you can just
type for hours and hours every day and
you know but because I do so many other
things I think that now I just I would
just really love to just have that be
automated you know I gotta I'm you know
I'm getting to in a place now where I
have a few younger writers that I'm
working with where I can sort of outline
this story not for everything you know
there's certain films that I'm like okay
this is just my baby right here but
certain projects where I'll do an
outline and then I'll send it to them
and then they can write the script based
on my outline and then send it back and
then I'll just like punch it up you know
so that's been that's been pretty cool
lately but but yeah I'm just trying to
I'm waiting on that magic thing where I
don't have to type anymore you know what
about writing in long-form
you or no uh you know it's cool cuz like
when I like when I started out I started
on the old school typewriter like with
the big keys that come out and you know
to keep you know like I started that's
how I started and then moved to like the
electric typewriter and then the
computer but um but yeah I just think um
I just I just want to talk I just want
to talk and have something just typed
for me I if I could never physically
type another script again I would be
great that'd just be awesome is that
because you don't like the the
screenplay format you know you'd rather
do it almost a novel form and then I
just think it's just the the physical
act of like that because it takes so
much brainpower to write it's very like
exhausting like it it it uh and just
like it just takes your soul you know
it's like so I think it's just that part
of it like I loved I loved telling
stories and I still have a lot of things
I want to say but I think because of the
fact that I I still edit I still shoot I
still direct I still do sound designer
certain products I still do you know
like because I'm doing all that other
stuff you know when I want to physically
have to type a script like I might get a
couple pages and I'm done like you know
I have to really be like unless I'm mom
[Music]
you know you're so in it and you're
trying to just get it out of your head
you know that's different but uh I try
to set goals though like because because
uh I'm older now says it's harder to
write as much as I did before so I try
to set goals like a certain amount of
pages or that sort of thing like um I
started
that way you know just break it into
sections you know right now I'm writing
uh finishing up the almighty street team
I'm finishing that adapting those comic
books and toe script and I've probably
got 30 pages left like I'm almost there
but but yeah it's been a process of and
that's been difficult to like adapting
something that already exists like a
comic book or doing an adaptation it's
very different than when you're sort of
coming up with something completely
original it's sort of riding that line
of how much do you keep how much do you
change sort of bringing it from a comic
book into live-action there's certain
things that are gonna operate
differently so that's been a unique
challenge this is the first time I've
done that adapted anything that it was
pre-existing so that's been like a
unique challenge like an interesting one
but but very different because I want to
stay true to the spirit and of the
material and then there's a great
moments in the material that you
definitely want in there and then
certain places you have to sort of
expand it to make it work but I think I
found a really good space with it you
know
you